[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause] [Music]
it's mother's day in mexico but this
march was not a celebration
it was a protest that's become an annual
event in mexico city to remember missing
persons
there's nothing to celebrate here
because a child cannot be replaced and
their presence at the table is missed
[Music]
emotions ran high as strangers shared in
each other's anger and despair
son went missing last august she says
the pain of having a son or a daughter
go missing never goes away
i'm not the only one we are many i don't
only speak for myself i speak for all
the disappeared because it's unfair that
organized crime takes away so many young
men and women to do whatever they want
with them
the number of disappeared in mexico is
fast approaching 100 000 some have been
missing since records began in the 60s
but the vast majority of disappearances
have been reported since 2006 when
former mexican president felipe calderon
declared a war on drugs though mexico's
current president andres manuel lopez
obrador promised to reduce
disappearances some 30 000 people were
reported missing in the country in just
the first three years of his presidency
as the number of missing persons in
mexico has steadily increased over the
past few decades so has public pressure
on the government to do more to end the
crisis of the disappear
experts say the problem of
disappearances in mexico is made worse
by a culture of impunity where few cases
of missing persons are ever investigated
and even fewer are solved
insolent government why are you doing
this to us we didn't ask to be victims
do something so we can know what
happened to our children i'm begging you
the backgrounds of missing persons are
diverse some of them victims of cartel
violence others are migrants like carlos
eduardo monroy who went missing just
over a month ago his family says the
search has been exhausting they say that
missing migrants are often ignored by
authorities
migrants have rights too they deserve to
be heard i know they try to cross the
border illegally but they are still
human beings they still have families
frustration over worsening insecurity
disappearances and gender-based violence
have sparked similar demonstrations in
recent weeks the response from mexico's
president has been a promise to address
these issues and avow that injustice in
mexico is a thing of the past although
these mother's day protesters say they
are proof that much more still needs to
be done
manuel rapalo al jazeera mexico city